[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream q a segment did we
establish it was 154 we did 154 is the
answer to that question see we've
already got one answered all right all
right we should stop where we're heading
no it doesn't work like that
not enunciating anymore today it's not
done enunciating yeah apparently it's
gonna be slurring from here on out yes
without any alcohol even all right let's
start with the question from Discord
this week they uh they send it a
question of their choice every week and
that's where we start
uh which you you can get on there on our
patreons
regarding the phenomenon in which a
fetus can give stem cells to its mother
with which she can repair damage to her
body
could this be a factor in why women tend
to live longer
probably not I mean no
gonna be a factor yes it almost
certainly is a factor to the extent that
it's real
um but first of all bearing children
very hard on the body
um so to the extent that a fetus can
provide stem cells that is compensating
for the damage that a fetus does in the
process of doing what fetuses do
it's also true that the uh females of
species tend to live longer than males
of species phenomenon is more widespread
than just mammals
and so you you have that being true in
species that don't gestate and so there
has to be an explanation that goes
beyond that even if it has some truth to
it yeah and even in humans let's say
once we correct for things that happen
after someone says hold my beer or any
of those kinds of phenomena
um there's still a a bias and
the long and short of it is more or less
this
if you think about
um
The Mating systems that human beings
will have lived under
a male competing with other males can
produce a very large number of Offspring
this is not an advantage of males
because it is equally possible to
produce no Offspring whatsoever but the
intense competition for Reproductive
opportunities
will cause males to concentrate
awesomeness early in life rather than
distribute it across the lifespan so
this creates the Paradox more or less of
males being stronger and more fragile in
the long run which is really what is
causing this pattern
so effectively a male who distributed
awesomeness evenly over a lifetime might
never win a competition whereas a male
who biased awesomeness to a very narrow
period of time
it's more likely to win in that period
of time but the point is it is borrowed
from somewhere
I will say there is one other Factor
here which
follows from my telomere work which
suggests that because telomeres on
non-sex chromosomes are inherited
without respect to sex
that the limitation on cellular repair
will fall more profoundly on males
because males are larger and therefore
burn up some of their lifetime capacity
for repair in growth
so that may be an independent reason
that males become more Fragile the
prediction would be that females have a
slight bias in favor of tumor
susceptibility even when we correct for
female specific tumors so do we know
what other patterns look like in species
where females are larger that's a great
question perps and like Raptors
Raptors for example yeah um I don't
think we do know
um
in in short what's going to be true is
you're going to have a bunch of
contributing factors and so in a species
in which size roles are reversed you
would expect some fraction of the bias
in favor of female longevity to be
to be
displaced I don't think size is a role
but you said size roles are diverse or
reversed you can identify as whatever
size you want so size rolls are a thing
a sexual sized dimorphism is the
opposite of what it is in mammals in
some species okay that would be a if you
wanted to convey meaning that would be a
way I like medium size
yeah it's it's it's late we've been
dealing with some weather so yeah all
right the uh English was not as well
deployed as it might have been the um
the I was this is a totally different
topic but speaking of some of what we've
been dealing with the fact that we've
been under a bunch of snow like really
unusually very unusually cold and snowy
for here uh and that it was promising to
go from not having been above freezing
for five days to completely above
freezing but still with like freezing
rain and snow and like you know icy
everywhere as we're just getting up this
morning suddenly a whole lot of water
from somewhere is what I'm hearing like
oh God what is happening there's no one
in the bathroom what is happening and uh
spigot outside just started gushing
doesn't see it like turned it off right
away you got to it uh it doesn't seem to
have done any damage but there's been a
whole lot of like oh God now what now
what yeah exactly I was pretty sure we
were in the clear I put my head in the
crawl space and I did not hear water I'm
not sure exactly what we would have done
if I had but uh you know we got it yeah
all right
let's go into the questions
um
that you have asked oh God it just
unsigned it signed me out I'm just gonna
you're gonna stall for a minute while oh
that was quick okay
we're totally done stalling all right
first question
I'm not sure I understand it but I'm
going to read it
via etymology
any word is the end of a long poem where
ideas get repurposed via compounding
metaphor verbing nouns Etc
for instance science comes from a root
notion of to separate also the source of
[ __ ]
didn't know that
how does language get bootstrapped what
is Underneath It All is symbolic
language all or none
unlike an eye
well I mean there's a I guess there's a
moment before symbolic language and a
moment after it right but then
you know metaphors in almost everything
that we say yeah right I mean even even
this is both obvious and not obvious but
one of the favorite one of my favorite
examples when I was teaching with
linguist for a couple of quarters we're
teaching a program called evolving
communication and I learned some things
about how linguists see the world in in
teaching with her for a couple of a
couple of quarters and the ubiquity of
metaphor uh was for me cemented with the
example of um higher of of warmer
temperatures being higher
Tire about them this is based on the
Mercury right this is based on mercury
thermometers and I actually it took me a
few go-arounds in my own head arguing
myself like no but they are higher it's
higher like
there's there's nothing inherent about
warmth versus coldness
okay so Zach says
sure
this is access this is not metaphor that
warmer temperatures are in fact
inherently higher
well there are several ways in which
they are specifically not altitude wise
the higher you go the colder it tends to
be well no but he but he is I know he's
going to make an argument I'm interested
to hear it but uh
but my argument is just that
it causes everything to expand because
things are working faster and so it
actually does there's more motion
there's more motion at warmer
temperature there is more motion so
that's there's more but is that higher
yeah I think this fits with us I don't I
don't know that more like activity more
activity isn't inherently higher no but
it's not more activity it's more space
so more space but more space Also isn't
higher
yeah right I'm not seeing it yeah um my
guess is like everything else or almost
everything else in language it is a
metaphor and uh we often don't spot
these things because they are dead
metaphors they are references to things
that we don't have a relationship with
um but even this one you know many
people at this point probably won't have
seen mercury thermometers but it's not
it's not dead to us and yet it's just so
it seems like such a true thing about
the thing that is being described yeah
and I'm still having a hard time this is
Zach taking it apart yeah
um yeah Zach doesn't agree yeah exactly
does not agree yeah he's free to be
wrong that's one of the great things
about uh being in North America or I was
just gonna say yeah you're free to be
wrong and very frequently you're in a
free in a position to um to impose your
will on others right or wrong uh
apparently yes
um but
uh what I was going to say no I think I
got it the question was is it all or
none unlike something like an eye now
this is an interesting way to put this
because eyes were one of the arguments
deployed against the uh graduated
gradualistic view of evolution and we
can get into a quagmire here
um
my feeling is evolution is
gradual
um which does not mean slow it means
graded
but just like but the the what the I
thing refers to I don't remember who
says like what good is half an I right
sometimes lots of good to have an eye
actually right and in fact Dawkins uh
has a tour de force on this one in I
think it might be climbing Mountain
probable anyway his point is not only is
every step along the way to a full eye
useful but we have examples of them in
nature and he goes through an
encyclopedic exploration of all of the
partial eyes from things that sense
light and dark to alert a creature that
a Shadows across them but
my point would be we know this is true
for language also
right anybody who's raised a child knows
this right there's a point where a child
might have one one word
and all they can do is signal
you know this is the moment for that
word and then they go and event
eventually they get to a place where
um you know they're saying
uh
things about morphology and complexity
and you know they're getting Advanced
degrees and stuff and the point is at
what stage along there was a little bit
more
linguistic capacity not useful and the
answer is nowhere it's as much as you
can muster is good
yeah though I don't think this question
was about
is functionality binary is it a symbolic
language all or none
and I get well I read it you so you're
approaching it from the perspective of a
single lifespan developmentally and I
was thinking about in terms of like some
are there
in the in the evolution of language
within a species within our species
would have to be
um or any of the evolutions of language
that have happened
any of the languages that have evolved
has there been a moment when there was
no symbolism
and I'm not sure I'm not sure but even
if so has there been a moment after
there was symbolism and then was it like
fully symbolic all of a sudden certainly
not well my point about development is
that you know frankly I think this is a
general point right we we have
creationists of various Stripes who will
protest about whether or not we could
have evolved they never bothered to
protest that we developed and my point
is it's the identical Miracle but nobody
protests it because the evidence is
overwhelming right and so it is the fact
that the evolutionary version of this is
depoporate and uh
incomplete
causes there to be head scratching over
whether it was possible but the evidence
you know the fact that as zygote turns
into a
Nobel Laureate right there's no stage
there where somebody says a miracle has
happened because we get what all the
stages are at some superficial level so
the fact that a child goes from saying
exactly nothing
to that same Nobel Laureate position and
that each stage along the way adds
some things that the child can specify
means that there's no Gap even if we
evolutionarily can't say what that
trajectory looked like
uh there's one other
I can't remember what the other point
was no doubt dawn on me three questions
from now
all right well you can come back to it
yep
um
if we got past the reproductive barrier
would trans still mean anything to the
average person
seems like the Holy Grail to passing
what's the current state of bottom
surgery and how close are we to
perfecting it oh
I didn't understand the question until I
got to the end so um
to to translate for those who didn't
have
probably most of you got it before we
did but
um it is if
if a man really could become a woman
like it if a human really could be a
transsexual
um
would
would this change how people viewed
trans and I guess maybe but it's a
non-issue because it's impossible
because mammals can't actually change
sex well okay a it will never become a
nothing right even if every person was
free to choose
even if it were possible even if even if
it were possible mammals were possible
it would not be nothing because you're
still the second so there will be a
question about you know uh
were you born with it or is it
Maybelline
that thing
um right
um
but
the
yep that's never going to be the same is
it
um but that's fine yeah I can destroy as
much of that kind of stuff as
advertising I'm free to absolutely take
it apart
um a we're nowhere we are nowhere with
respect to actually being able to
generate I mean I know how you would do
it if do you yeah more or less Which Way
both ways either way
if you're going to do it you would
basically you would what
I'm about to it's not going to be all
that it's not going to be
operationalizable yeah but what you
would do is you would take
cells and you would cause them to grow
organs that you were lacking and the
person who was going to transition based
on sending them information if they had
landed in these I go with the other
chromosomal complement right not saying
it's possible I mean we can't grow your
heart yet either but um
cyber genitals well
they've done something they're we are
along the road I don't think that they
have created a functional heart
certainly we can't hook one up properly
and it lasted for a few
so then we so then that's my point is we
didn't I'm not saying we didn't do
anything that you could call that but if
we didn't successfully grow a heart that
did the job and that's yeah in part
that's that's the telomere issue
it's going to be many different issues
anyway not not worth going into but the
point is if you were going to try to do
this that'd be the way to do it the
other way to do it is the Harrison
Bergeron way which is uh we wreck
everybody's reproductive capacity and it
becomes uh fetus farms and I did see
you're trying that aren't we yeah yeah I
saw the fetus Farm thing showed up
uh I don't know about the feet of
service but we do appear to be wrecking
everyone's reproductive both interest
and capacity through a variety of means
oh absolutely through a variety of means
yes a multiplicity of ways in which we
can
fun and utility out of sex what is this
this is a farm that you speak of what is
this fetus firm that I speak of it I did
not actually explore it because
basically I looked at it and I could
infer the entire system yeah that's
that's a bright that's an incredibly
dystopian phrase yeah oh absolutely what
does it mean oh it means raising babies
in the artificial wombs babies
gametes that have been donated
again I didn't I didn't delve into the
story but it appeared to be that
artificial wombs are now sort of barely
within technological range and of course
this will create humans that have all
manner of pathologies that you know we
could
um have a great deal of dystopian fun
predicting but nonetheless that's where
we are in history congratulations
um so you know I'm about saying
pregnancy is fun some women seem to
enjoy it I didn't I didn't but I
guarantee you it's necessary to produce
reasonable people yes oh totally
guarantee you
I mean I can put some of the stuff
that's missing I don't know why all of
it's important but
it's going to be necessary I vividly
remember you plunking yourself down in a
chair and some awkward late stage
pregnancy I'm saying this is a [ __ ]
stupid way to reproduce
you buy that I didn't argue I also stand
by I stand by that I also stand by my at
that point entirely joking insistence
that after the first one you would have
to carry the second one yep and uh you
being a biologist who knew that it was
not possible oh except my responsibility
and then when it didn't happen that way
you're like what what can I do no what
you don't know is it not a day goes by
that I am not grateful that men cannot
carry a human child
now to be fair you did a lot of carrying
after that oh yeah after they're born
sure that's cool yeah right but much
easier yeah before they're born thing
that just does not look like fun no no
you're not a seahorse so you gotta think
that's
for so many reasons for so many reasons
yeah no but I so I did some research on
seahorses
uh for this uh subside post a long time
ago and uh actually the degree of of
like
circulatory change in the follicles
during male gestation during what
amounts to male pregnancies and
seahorses is so closely analogous
to the follicular and cardio and in
circulatory changes in in female mammals
including human bodies when they're
pregnant it's it's an amazing
convergence like the male seahorses
really can be understood to be pregnant
it's just that the the zygote didn't
start there the zygote got moved by Mom
and then she's like it's all yours bud
yeah no it's it's crazy
um I do wonder you know a lot of these
discoveries are more recent than we
think I do Wonder at what point we got
ourselves
straightened out with respect to who
does what during seahorse pregnancy do
we have any idea how long you've
understood this I
I don't remember but I think it's not
that long ago yeah yeah I can imagine
doing that work on seahorse reproduction
and concluding okay that one just gave
birth that's a female yeah it's gotta be
because I must have done I must have
miscoded that one earlier in the
experiment yep yep totally
if the worst of the implications of the
CIA involvement with JFK are true
I think it's even worse than that would
a revolution be needed to rate the ship
so I actually have not followed what the
New Revelations are but it's not
actually New Revelations is it I mean
it's what a lot of us have thought along
depends how much you've been paying
attention Okay okay I mean no I mean I
really think that's where where we are
is it's like now yes we are definitely
somewhere new where we can talk about
the evidence that many of us have been
talking about for quite some time
um so I don't know
um so what is I I literally don't know
anything of what is supposedly new here
except that there is there is new now
we're now we're allowed to talk about it
well I haven't been paying attention I
know there was just a trove of documents
released as there is on some regular
schedule I know it had some stuff in it
I don't think it has the uh the big
unanswered questions addressed but it
does fill in pieces of the puzzle and
it's not like we didn't have a lot of
pieces of the puzzle pretty well filled
in before
um and there's this uh Tucker Carlson
Revelation where you know he's a
journalist and he's got a source who was
in a position to see
internal documents who said yeah the CIA
was involved in the assassination so
make of that what you will it's not like
a source couldn't have lied but
um
it will not be all that surprising in
light of the evidence if the CIA was
involved and
so so the second the question would a
revolution be needed to write the ship
would it even work
so I I think the problem is I've lost my
taste for that kind of Remedy because
it's not even obvious to me what it
would do yeah
so yes we need
um
we need the truth part of Truth and
Reconciliation if reconciliation is the
price let's do it but you know all of
the people involved are dead all the
important ones so
um
let's agree I mean this this is actually
goes back to what we were talking about
in the main podcast
are we gonna pull out of the nose dive
something went wrong in 1963 something
that we never fixed
where has not fixing it taken us it's
taken us to the brink of
self-destruction
maybe now would be a good time to say
well
whatever people were thinking those
people are now gone maybe we need to
know what they did maybe we need to
figure out how deep it goes and maybe we
need to reboot
something profound in our system because
the departure from democracy that began
with the assassination of JFK presumably
began
the assassination of JFK has been a
disaster
um
right something like that but I don't
yeah I don't Revolution I don't even
know what to make of that what would you
revolt against exactly yeah
yeah next question
what is a book when we're what is a book
or more my God try again a book I got
that much or material no more material
what is a book or material you would
suggest to study Game Theory you know I
keep being asked as I I made a tweet
years ago I kept being asked this and I
gave
was it my
10 most important Game Theory Concepts
that people should learn
um I'm not saying there isn't a book
there may well be a book that's not
where it's not where I Got Game Theory
and I'm not sure you need it
I will also say there was um
why am I blanking on its name
there was a gentleman working on some
animations to reveal these Central
Concepts
some years ago David why am I forgetting
David's last name
um anyway maybe I will come up with it
but
um
it would be great if there was a book if
there is I don't know enough about any
book to recommend that this is the book
and that isn't the book but Game Theory
you can pick up these Concepts there
aren't that many of them that you need
and they are described widely you will
find videos on each of them if you want
to pursue them and I would argue that
you should build up your model
based on these things and that you know
I'm not sure a book would be more
effective
yeah
yeah I was just thinking there are a
couple of
there are a couple of seminal papers use
the word
whoa yeah
um and I've got axelrodden Hamilton
which is I just pulled it up because I
forgot what year it was it's 1981 the
evolution of cooperation
you've got Garrett Hardin tragedy the
commons late 60s
both of those published in science back
before science went
whatever science went
um not everybody yeah yeah
uh uh there's gonna be something really
straightforward from um
there are a couple of other really clean
simple papers and I think actually
Dawkins
does a very good job in the selfish Gene
in a couple of chapters as well and it's
Christmas dilemma prisoner's dilemma
um so that's not it's not an answer and
like we I do wish that there was a
resource that we could Point people to
but um Axelrod and Hamilton the
evolution of Corporation hardened
charging the commons selfish Gene by
Dawkins which is a book which is very
important you know a little dated at
this point but surprisingly not as data
as you would expect even that it was
published in 1976.
um
I'll add one more thing there's a couple
of others really obvious papers that I
can't think of at the moment
um I'm going to add a kind of Applied
I'm sure it doesn't mention the term
Game Theory
um but
there is a great paper actually a friend
of ours asked me we had referred to it
and he asked me for the paper I sent it
to him earlier this week emlin and oring
oh
yeah and so my point about emlin and
orang emblem
ornithologists are ornithologists who
published a paper that basically said
you could predict the mating system of a
species
based on two fundamental parameters
which had to do with the spacing of food
and the predation pressure experienced
by creatures in that species and their
point was which which is to say spacing
and timing
yeah
so their point was if you
know these parameters then you can
figure out how females will distribute
themselves in a landscape predation
drives females together food competition
drives them apart and so to the extent
that you can specify something if the
food
uh
uh the distribution of food causes
females to forage independently than
males are relegated to deploying one
strategy if the food resources allow
females to Clump such that they are more
immune to their predators by virtue of
schooling Behavior effectively or
hurting Behavior then males will deploy
a different strategy they effectively
are monopolizable by males by small
numbers of males a small number of males
and you see the conditions ripe for the
evolution of polygyny right so anyway
the point is it's such a great example
of the power of this style right the
basic point is that males are not
driving the choice of these systems
males are responding in a tiny number of
logical ways to a parameter over which
they have no control
and it creates
these you know creates all sorts of
things it creates you know
running Antelope with antlers right
um
so you can just wait a second show me
spreading antelope
no
it creates running deer with antlers
exactly yeah a distinction being that
horns aren't dropped right yep uh and
they're also made of different material
yeah uh antlers are also skeletal but
um they're disposable skeleton yeah
they're I think they're not they're not
covered exoskeleton
um here it is Zach just to show my
screen here for a moment so uh hi like
this is one of the very few if not the
only like this other two papers I
mentioned are also really good this one
is one I pulled it up to the evolution
of Corporation by Axel run Hamilton but
this which is also published in science
1977 ecology sexual selection on the
evolution of many systems
I think I used I think I assigned this
every single year um it is just extreme
it is so beautifully done it is so and
it's short
uh and it's clean and it's just careful
like it like if you want an example of
how to think evolutionarily the ways
that that we do that we try to like it
is just it is as beautiful on this paper
yep and I think people who
are more used to
science and the way it's developed in
the present will be surprised that this
paper is not stupid and wrong yeah okay
lots of predictions that could falsify
what they're talking about oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah that kind of sort of a
scientific
thinking yeah yeah without any
science-ish or sciency stuff right yeah
um you've grown cynical yeah
yeah and I don't think it's you know
snarky I'll cop the snarky I'm not going
to Coptic cynicism yet okay fair enough
okay
um
do you think musk could or should apply
a First Amendment abiding Free Speech
policy for example could a Twitter exist
where Kanye doesn't get banned
um I believe
it would be a mistake to try to apply
the First Amendment directly as if
Twitter was governmental
because you don't want to hold yourself
responsible
we hog tie the federal government we hog
tie all government from violating First
Amendment rights because it is necessary
due to the Ferocious power of the state
you can back that off
in order to manage something like
Twitter
while defending the value
right there's lots of you know let's
take doxing for example
it may be legal to dock somebody it has
no value it has a danger and it is quite
possible to create a Twitter in which
that does not exist where a
protected mode of speech does not exist
because it literally creates no value in
in the space of Twitter
likewise you could
um you know you could ban sexually
explicit content which
is sexually explicit content deserving
of first amendment protection yeah it is
um is it okay to create a space where it
isn't because the value it adds to the
space is less than the cost to the space
sure so I don't think the first
amendment should be applied to Twitter I
believe that the value of the First
Amendment with respect to expressing
ideas and differences of opinion is the
key thing that Twitter is well
positioned to be important
uh with respect to and so it's the
spirit of the first amendment that
should be applied to Twitter not the
letter
cool
thank you kindly for another year of
logical thinking in comfortable pets
if dogs beget dogs and frogs beget frogs
how did frogs forget dogs
well
is frogs didn't forget dogs no frogs
didn't have to get dogs the stem
ancestor the listen the amphibian
ancestor of frogs
share
went down a different branch that
ultimately became dogs in one of its
many branches uh frogs are modern
amphibians that
um do not we do not
um we were never frogs
we were amphibians we came out of the
water uh and became tetrapods and had to
retool everything
you know respiratory
visual olfactory locomotory muscle
systems like everything had to be
retooled once we are now on land rather
than in water
um and the early that early tetrapod
which was an amphibian was not a frog or
toad or salamander or a newt or a
sicilian and all toads of frogs and all
newts or salamanders so there's just
three types of modern amphibians but
that early one that for those first ones
weren't any of those because those
evolved later from that stem
ancestor yep I would add just one other
thing
if you think about the world in which
our ancestor
went through this amphibious phase
and you think so the world already had
on it plants
insects Etc and you think about in
animal relegated to life in the water an
animal really constrained to it you know
a traditional fishy fish as it were
well a fishy fish that can reach a foot
beyond the highest place that the water
gets to has whatever opportunity is
there and there's actually quite a bit
right you could find dead things that
had fallen in the water that wash up to
the Meander line and a creature they can
access that thing one foot beyond the
water as an advantage so you would
expect there is pressure to innovate the
ability to just go just a little farther
and the point I'm getting at is
that is also true
um two feet from the water there are
opportunities that one foot is not
enough it's true three feet from the
water and so and sometimes what's you
know eight feet from the water is the
next pool right that isn't drying up
and so anyway what I would say is in the
context of what we call the Adaptive
landscape where opportunities are Peaks
you have a gentle slope right the point
is the farther you can get from the
water the better off you are and the
thing about amphibians is amphibians are
constrained to water for reproduction
but they get better and better at
reaching farther and farther from the
water and there is nothing but
opportunities out there and then the
thing that uh amniotes do that is to say
the reptiles that descended from those
amphibian ancestors is they have eggs
that are tolerant of not being in water
so they have the ability to get even
that much farther and really what you're
talking about
is a kind of exploring where the farther
you go
the more Advantage there is so the
pressure to keep innovating how do I get
just a little farther than the last one
escape the competition of everybody
who's gotten to the one foot level by
getting to the three foot level if
they're empty niches uh there is uh
opportunity for exploration opportunity
and pressure preparation so I would just
say that when you say reptiles I know
that you are including
that's riptilomorphs uh and and also
includes what will become mammals and
therefore includes us yes what's that
said the reptile said the reptile yes no
totally
um and yeah of course reptiles include
Spurs I guess I guess what I'm really
getting at is
there can be a niche that is so
displaced from the creature that might
access it that it's impossible or nearly
impossible to get there that is not the
case when you have a gentle slope where
every intervening stage gets you some
advantage and so you would expect the
evolution of something
um
terrestrial tetrapati from a amphibious
ancestor because there's no place at
which getting more access to the land it
doesn't provide a new Advantage it's a
lot of pressure it's very consistent so
somewhere in there
is the answer to the question that you
were asking how is it that uh frogs
which Heather and I will take to be
ancestral amphibians give rise
to dogs and the answer is constant
constant evolutionary pressure in that
direction which provided reward all
along the way
with
with some moments like you have to move
on to land is is as I started by saying
you're really gigantic you just you have
to retool I mean just just think about
the different refractive indices of
water versus Air
and then the different pressure that is
placed on You by gravity on land versus
in water now you are
you a kind of shallow water dwelling
fishy thing that also is getting some
four legs that can kind of do some
moving around in shallow water and
occasionally you're sticking your snout
up and maybe gulping some air and such
that's a totally different landscape
from being on land and having gravity
womp like down on you and you know you
you you're also at that point in the
sort of splayed the splayed position
where it's you've been moving as a fish
from side to side and now gravity is
putting even more pressure on you to
smash your flat to the Earth's surface
so there's just you know that that is a
remarkable moment the move to land the
evolution of tetrapods of tetrapodi but
also of all the other things that have
to happen because it is such a giant
transition and therefore you know not
only is that the subject of a lot of of
research interests but so too are the
returns to the Sea so you know we have
in mammals
three or four returns to the Sea partial
and complete you know we have the whales
which includes the Dolphins and we have
the manatees and we have the pinnipeds
which is the seals and sea otters and
walruses and then they're partials sorry
seals and sea lions and
and walruses and then the partial
Returns the sea otters yep right uh and
River Riders actually the Otters the
Otters are sort of a partial return but
you also have in reptile space sea
snakes uh which
um actually
uh go on land in these little like
shelves and caves largely to uh to
reproduce but they otherwise live
entirely in the water I think I remember
wearing that correct yes at least at
least it may not be every species yeah
at least some of the sea snakes do that
and incidentally the sea snakes are all
of their lapins they're most closely
related to things like cobras they're
super crazy dangerous but they're mostly
pretty Placid because you're an idiot if
you mess with a snake in the water yeah
wouldn't do it yeah yeah there have
definitely been obstacles the Fighting
Gravity thing is rough uh the drying out
I mean just I mean like it's winter here
like we're all like oh God our skin is
so dry well imagine if you've never been
in air at all and now so we have this um
the stratum corneum
um is this new new evolutionary feature
of tetrapods that allows for skin not to
be just constantly losing water yeah the
amnio well that's later the amnion in
the egg that's later though right okay
got the order wrong what the I've got
the order wrong
what was your first one on the list the
stratium corneum stratium corneum yes
which is a term I'm just looking at one
of my lectures now a layer of dead skin
cells usually keratinized which also is
a tetrapod's net worth all right
stratium corneum comes before the amnion
which protects the egg
then there's the uh the gravitational oh
no that's going to be second in this
list I'm not going to do it I can't do
this okay I thought you weren't uh you
weren't building the pun here
uh I was going to argue that among the
many challenges you had the the Hoover
administration
um it was a challenge it came rather
later yes a little bit a little bit
someone later yeah okay
um
the evolution of the neck
yes seriously
how do fish who are trying to like
nibble the algae off of coral
get position themselves they move their
whole bodies right if you've ever been
in the water if you've ever snorkeled or
scuba dive or anything they move their
whole bodies they don't need necks
they don't have any different necks once
you're on land you won't be able to do
this you don't have to move your whole
body and so the neck happens at the
level of tetrapod right I mean imagine
how would you shush somebody behind you
in the theater if you didn't have a neck
yeah theater definitely evolves after
neck
right for reasons that should now be
obvious to our audience embarrassing
embarrassing Evolution biologists my God
okay
um
which one was that uh dogs bigot dogs
Etc okay we have a three-part it's just
in three pieces here that I'm not sure I
know what it means
loved you too question in mosquitoes
Game Theory
citizens are divided in two blocks
rulers choose to reward or Not by
amalgamating people of color or LGBT or
women in trans women minorities a number
of blocks can be minimized moving the
system
towards more authoritarianism
while questioning black Trans lives
mattering means excommunication
intersectionalists can cash out though
thoughts
I'm gonna have to sit down with this and
and yeah because I think that I think
the premise is a mosquitoes mosquito I
don't know what the premise is
do you have any thoughts or ideas about
the causes of mass whale beachings
is that happening now
I don't know that that's happening now I
don't know that is happening now yeah
um
I would if that's happening now I'd like
to know that it is but I don't know it
yeah I've got some some thoughts hey
there's a question about whether or not
an animal that is going to die is taking
itself out of the water you know
we don't leave corpses on the surface we
bury them is this you know something of
that nature is there a reason that
having the
corpse in an area
where relatives are going to be swimming
would be bad
um that would not
predict beachings where animals are just
passing through which I think are as far
as we know somewhat common nowhere to
predict beachings of apparently young
healthy animals yes well that's the
question is how often are you missing a
pathology right if a whale had a
leukemia
you know and necropsy wouldn't
necessarily reveal it or maybe it would
um but in any case don't know there's
there's lots to be answered it's also
possible that these animals are being
disrupted by human alterations to things
you know we'll introduce all kinds of
noises and chemicals and could we be
just disrupting something and the
question is how common is yeah how
common would these things be places they
have to avoid because they're polluted
either you know the things we can see or
more often probably like chemically
polluted like oh that can't take the
usual route I would take because that's
going to be toxic to me I have to go
this way oh damn yeah made an error
if the person now Elliott page
now called Elliot page committed a crime
when he was Ellen Page pre-transition
but it was only discovered
post-transition who would be charged or
would the D.A be unable to file charges
because the person no longer exists
I mean this is part of the problem with
the whole identity thing and this is
part of what you were arguing in the
first couple hours is you know you don't
you're you are the same person
you can change your name you can change
your hair color you can change how you
present you can say that you've changed
your gender identity but that's not a
real thing so whatever
um and you can change how you present to
the world in terms of what sex you
present as even though you cannot change
what sex you actually are but you're
still the same person you can't that's
not
that's not negotiable history is history
yep uh so
yeah you know similarly you know for any
of these
in front of these people who have
declared themselves radically different
from who they used to be if a crime was
discovered from before then well
um blood changed I hope you changed a
lot but you still committed a crime and
you still need to be held accountable
yep
following the Mrs Miz and Ms logic
wouldn't adding a genderless pronoun
makes sense
pronoun
I I guess I read that the first time as
honorific like wouldn't adding a
genderless honorific make sense and I
don't know that that's not what it's
meant here
we can try to address
yeah I don't see this argument no but I
do like a generalist honorific
I still you know I still a sexless
really right like
the thing is male and female are real
and they do
they they they don't change and you wear
as you can change if you're married or
not right
um and there should be situations where
it actually doesn't matter if it's a man
or a woman that is going to be writing
the report for something right but yeah
but uh
I really this is suggested with some
regularity and I which the pronoun
right because so I was I was referring I
was responding to what I thought they
might have met which is the honorific
generous honorific
even that I I'm not convinced that it's
a great idea because it's not the same
thing but not only is it not the same
thing but it is a cryptic attack on
meaning
okay if there is such a thing as
transitioning in some sense it is
transitioning from one thing to another
so you've landed in the category that
already exists okay
but there are many aspects of reality
that don't get referred to in our
honorifics doesn't make any difference
if I say you know
um
well I I now see a problem which is the
doctor
is genderless and so it creates the very
problem I'm going to complain about most
I mean most of these meritocratic earned
earned titles
are often
gen ungendered I think Esquire actor
professor
yeah in any case
in some if
you say Mr or Miz
you are providing a clue to
linguistically how to
continue on with a discussion right if
um you know
Ms Henderson has presented a paper that
something you know sheep what would she
argue yeah right so it provides evidence
if it's you know Dr Henderson that I
don't know whether I'm supposed to say
he or she so that actually creates a
problem but the the reason that I'm
really bristling at this is
there's an idea well if you believe in
trans then we should do something for
them and the answer is if I believe in
trans then they have transitioned from a
category we had to a different category
we had I don't need to break up language
or become authoritarian and force people
to do something they haven't been doing
to deal with this if I believe that this
is real the categories already exist the
language already exists and I don't want
to create a special privilege
well I guess I would I disagree with one
thing you said there which is that
someone
who is trans is transitioning from a
category we had to a new category well
in every sense that is Meaningful that's
what they're doing they are either not
transitioning at all right an important
if you have talking about their
chromosomes they haven't done a damn
thing if they have if they're going to
transition so that the gametes that they
could produce right so that's socially
we are
going to treat them by this new category
they've transitioned to a category for
which we had language and I want to
create a special privilege for this
right so it doesn't require it and the
old frankly here here's the best
argument against it
let's say that we did create a
genderless pronoun for people who had
transitioned aren't we now ghettoizing
them
aren't we now saying well this isn't a
real woman well a there's then going to
be pressure for everyone to use that one
right right uh
uh and
I saw another problem that I lost
yeah I think I think in any case we're
at the same place which is you are
creating a problem
in order to solve a non-problem and you
are deciding that because there's
linguistic complexity surrounding how we
deal with this
that the right thing to do is to fix the
language and the answer is no fix the
issue figure out what it is you are and
are not entitled to do and what it does
and does not change about where you're
allowed to go and you know the language
comes last not first and to the extent
that because language is the easy place
to say here is the answer to the
question that the people who are
pointing to the language are in a
position to discuss the complexities of
this no these are the last people yeah
right these people do not understand the
real complexities they want to deal with
the language because it doesn't require
a lot of work for them to figure out
what to command
yep
when did we start Zach
all right
we're gonna stop soon then
humans appear to have a brain circuit
for dividing in half visually not other
fractions thoughts on causes is it just
for sharing reasons
I don't know that I agree with the
premise here I'm not sure I know what
we're talking about
it is you can look at something that the
premise is humans can look at something
and say okay half there half here yep
but humans don't tend to do as good a
job with quarters or thirds or fifths
no
of course quarters 8 16 of course is is
easy because it's just more Habs so
that's maybe cheating
um but thirds I feel like a lot of
people can do I can do
um and it's not as precise though so
maybe the maybe the point is like yeah
we're a lot better have have no but the
smaller the fraction the less precise
it's going to be so it's not I'm not
convinced that this actually
better at quarters than thirds yeah
because it's another half it is smaller
and
in any case even even if it's the case
I'm not sure how much of this is
inherent and how much of this is
Downstream of the math that we study in
school and yeah and the kind of visual
framework that we grow up in so the
question would be you know are there are
there other cultures who grow up in very
different environments in which people
have a really easy time dividing things
in the fifths for instance yeah you know
and and do those cultures have
fruits that emerge for three months of
the year where depending on you know if
you cut them the way that is traditional
to cut them in that culture they happen
to be uh
pentagonally symmetric readily symmetric
with five parts right there are fruits
like that sure
um so it seems yeah it seems likely to
be a developmental situation
I understand about oxytocin but what
might be an evolutionary explanation for
the tendency of men to fall asleep after
sex we're stumped maybe to encourage the
woman to stay put increasing the
likelihood of pregnancy question mark
hmm
I don't know I've actually I've never
given this any thoughts yeah well I mean
hey I don't know about the
you know there's obviously something to
it but the fact that sex is relegated to
bed I'm just not sure how to disentangle
well yeah so I don't know yeah if if uh
are men really likely to fall asleep
after sex
at nine in the morning
kind of don't think so yeah noon I don't
know I don't know I don't know how to
answer the question yeah so it's I guess
maybe that's why it just this seemed
like uh just maybe a conflation of like
yeah or you know if if it's in an
elevator
I'm not sure I'm not sure it's not just
a Trope yeah
yeah
okay uh
or a Trope or Downstream of
uh you know particular cultures
credit elections yeah okay we actually
only have three more here and two of
them are just are ones that
yeah quick with the Twitter files coming
out maybe you should ask Elon Musk if
there was any more information about the
censorship of unity 2020.
I absolutely want to know yeah
um Merry Christmas and happy Hanukkah
what are some of your favorite holiday
books movie shows songs and traditions I
don't have an answer to that right now
but in the pursuit of getting all of the
questions answered this week I thought
I'd read it do you have any
no I mean I think surviving the holidays
is no we're not going there
um I always did like of of the um it's a
snark about the olives in the middle no
why why
because I don't have an answer I don't
know that I have these traditions
do you what are some of your favorite
holiday books movie shows songs and
traditions I mean we have a Hanukkah
tradition that we wrote about in
hunter-gatherers guide I always love a
Christmas tree
um lit with simple lights and a lot of
pretty glass ornaments just a lot of
Reflections a lot yeah a lot of lights
and the two
Christmas carols that I think I am most
drawn to are silent night and Oh Holy
Night all right all right and Zach has
something to add too it's gonna be
snarky no it's not snarky
I have always liked the song Baby it's
cold outside and it has become my
absolute favorite now that it drives bad
people crazy awesome okay yeah and Zach
who is not miked for some reason yes
okay sounds good uh Coldplay and Fleet
Foxes as wonderful winter bands
cold pay Coldplay and Fleet Foxes yes I
don't know Fleet Foxes I do okay okay
and are they winter bands just because
of the names three songs Okay Christmas
lights by Coldplay
Light Winter Hymnal I don't know if they
can hear me but White Winter Hymnal by
Fleet Foxes and Christmas lights
Christmas lights by Coldplay
songs well you should you should uh we
should listen to these tonight with your
grandparents
you have been with them
okay
all right
okay
um final question at what age actually
perfect segue at what age do you start
letting your kids go out unsupervised
you're really too early
without the neighborhood crew it's just
not the same as when we were kids
that's definitely true although
um we were lucky to have bought
you know they until four and a half
years ago we lived in Olympia and we
literally lived across a dead end Road
from the Thousand Acre Evergreen campus
that's mostly forest and so they were
able to go out into the forests from the
young age
um once we had the dog with their dog
but even before we had the dog uh and
play and build stuff and explore and
and we also they also at some point I
don't remember when Jack moved in across
the street but um a a friend of Toby is
exactly Toby's age moved in across the
street and so it was a little bit of a
crew there um
but it is different on the other hand we
didn't we both grew up in sort of
suburban-ish for La neighborhoods and
did to some degree have like a crew that
we could run around with yeah but and
our kids didn't but they also didn't
grow up in Suburbia in the same way
right in fact you know the 70s and 80s
you went out with your crew if you
didn't come back it was your time
more or less how I think the adults
thought of it
[Laughter]
happy holidays everyone
life is cheap apparently yes oh yeah
um that's it I guess that's it that's it
we will be back on New Year's Eve and
before then there will be another dark
ice Dark Horse episode dropping on
Wednesday of this week but uh New Year's
Eve will be back we will we will see you
then now you will see us then if you
choose to we will not see you then but
we'll know you're there
and uh until then because of the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]